خلال ثلاثه اشهر خفضت تسلا اسعارها في
الصين بنسبه وصلت الى 24% لبعض طرزان ما
الذي يرعب تسلى ويدفعها الى الدخول في حرب
اسعار ساعرفكم الى الوحش الصيني الذي يفرض
سيطرته على سوق السيارات الكهربائيه
مهدداشه انها بوادي الصينيه تسلم ما زالت
حتى اليوم اكبر منتج في العالم للسيارات
الكهربائيه بالكامل بنحوي مليون و300,000
سياره مقارنه ب 900 واحد 10,000 سياره
لبودي لكن اذا اضفنا سيارات الكهربائيه
الهجينه
وهي عباره عن سيارات الهجينه قابله للشحن
تصبح بوادي رقم واحد عالميه يعني وصلت الى
مليون
و860,000 سياره في 20 22 والاهم انها تخطي
طول لنمو هائل استهدفوا لبيعي اربعه
ملايين سياره في عام 20/03
بوادي في الطرقات والسبب ان مبيعاتها
تتركز في الصين بلاد المليار و400 مليون
سنه لكن الوضع قد يتغير في السنوات
المقبله وتسلى تشعر بتهديد كبير ولذلك
قامت بتخفيض اسعار سياراتها بشكل حاد
لتثير غضب من اشتروا طرازاتها مؤخرا حتى
الان تعد سيارته الكهربائيه من علامات
رفاهيه نظرا لاسعارها فهل تتوقع ان تؤدي
المنافسه الشرسه الى خفض الاسعار لتصبح في
المتناول
[موسيقى]